So speaking of someone who hasn't
actually seen a lot of the OG Dragon
Ball anime every time I do check it out
I am just flabbergasted by some of the
insane filler in there why did no one
tell me the anime invented evil Nimbus
in the manga telepipai beats up Goku
Goku ascends Karen Tower and trains
comes back down and beats Tau Papi's ass
it's a tale as old as time it's simple
it's beautiful it's chef's kiss right
but apparently in the anime at some
point taupai Pai also goes up to the
tower and threatens Karin until he is
given some tap water and then Karen
summons an evil Nimbus for him to write
what is happening here exactly as a
manga reader I swear watching the Dragon
Ball anime feels like someone slips
something into my drink just before I
started watching this if nothing else
though the little evil Nimbus totally
owns title pie pie in the end so really
it was all worth it in the end and
friendship was the real treasure